the streets of Iran echoed to the sound
of collective Fury as a popular
Rebellion enters its fourth consecutive
month
the public are trying to break with the
past but their clerical rulers are
determined to preserve it and their
methods have become increasingly violent
some are beaten others are shocked and
several protesters convicted of Waging
War against God have been executed
amongst those facing the death penalty
is a professional footballer called Amir
Nazir azadani prosecutors say the 26
year old is a militant trying to
overthrow the state but his friends say
that's ridiculous yeah I mean it was one
of the young guys at the time in in our
Squad and he was like 19 20 years old at
the time
um quite quite the shy person but
really really kind and
let's say respectful towards the all the
players in this in the team
this is Sebastian stranvall in action
for Top Flight finish side VPS varsa but
in 2015 he spent the season in Tehran
where he got to know Nazir azadani was a
really big shock when I sort of
or when I read about the news about him
yeah how did you feel about it it feels
so far
from reality so surreal feeling you know
that someone might be facing a death
sentence for
for participating in PS4 protests when
the young Iranian found himself without
accommodation stranval let him sleep on
his sofa the pair became firm friends
him and his friends would
stand up for basic human rights for
women's rights of course because he's a
person who cares about other people but
I don't see see him like doing war on
God
top Iranian footballers on the country's
National side have been engulfed by the
crisis and we're roundly criticized by
many for playing in the World Cup
when the so-called regime team lost its
final match to the U.S people took to
the streets to celebrate
but these scenes of Jubilation angered
the authorities
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a 22 year old called farzen was
reportedly shot as he celebrated Iran's
exit from the tournament his father
brought a cake to the gravesite to honor
his birthday a date his son would never
see
Amir Nasir azadin is one of dozens of
protesters who now face the death
penalty and a German MP Andreas larim
has taken up his case A desperate
Mission this to keep him alive you
should know that that we we stand with
him and and that we really Force on
every side where we can get him out and
his and his friends being also in the
prison get out of that of that situation
and I would like to see him and to met
him in Germany
people of influence will be targeted as
the clerics try to salvage their regime
but they have already lost many of their
citizens
John Sparks Sky News